shut up
stop hitting
i'm just thinking it
check check test
little fake it's a clapper so i can see
the thing and then sync
it's one of these things you do to make
believe that you're doing something but
it's not anything it's
was is it sea world seals
you throw me a fish well if i had a
clapper if i just went like this
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what people are talking about
we're rolling i know we are it's the tim
dillon can you sit in your chair and do
the show where are you going i was
looking for my water your water
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show if we can even call it that
if everybody settled down our friends
devin uh costa ida tavakoli join us uh
this evening
for the uh
broadcast
devon looks uh
completely out of it and then i look
very poised she's sitting there very
poised like we're gonna yeah i'm gonna
really
you know really get into it yeah here
are the issues of the day
greg norman golfer ben's friend says uh
we all make mistakes regarding jamal
khashoggi's murder tell us everybody
quickly what's going on with
the saudi because saudis own everything
now they own a stake in live nation they
own free speech
they own a lot of the great real estate
in america now they also somehow have
gotten golf yeah yeah they got the
saudis on golf now they can have it live
yes live golf so that's what i say so
for anyone that doesn't know greg norman
was a huge golfer in the 80s and the 90s
the shark from australia australia right
and uh so they gave him a war chest of
about 350 million dollars to get as many
players over to the pga tour from the
pga tour to the saudi tour which is
going to take place in the u.s what's
the saudi tour called live golf l.i.v
golf they love like names like that
live golf
so this organization it's a fun of saudi
arabia arabia they're going to get
people from the pga tour to play in
these events it looks like they got phil
mickelson with like 40 million dollars
to crosstalk he's in all kinds of
gambling debts he needs help that's the
rumors he owes people tons and like
millions of dollars it's always been a
rumor he had huge problems with gambling
but supposedly he's doing this to get uh
he owed bones makai his caddy hundreds
of thousands get two in the weeds
because no one cares except you about
golf no one cares bones makai well he
does he does this no one gives a [ __ ]
and he keeps i want broad strokes to
just we can understand what's happening
so
so uh so he's getting players from the
pga tour over to the saudi tour if they
go to the saudi tour they are banned
from the pga tour interesting and he's
getting big players with uh money
right
and so now they keep asking them about
saudi arabia they keep going hey don't
you you know what about the human rights
violations and he basically says things
like
what are you gonna do
and so they asked him about
so ahead of the group's inaugural event
said for june 9 11 september 11th
not september 11th june
9 11 but what does that mean june 9th
through the 11th june 9th through the
11th odd
the first saudi golf tournament
is the 9th through the 11th of june
that's odd
at centurion golf club outside of london
norman was asked his thoughts on saudi
arabia's involvement in the 2018 murder
of washington post reporter and united
states resident jamal khashoggi
quote from what i heard and what you
guys reported norman said
just take ownership of what it is take
ownership no matter what it is look
we've all made mistakes
and you just want to learn from those
mistakes and how you can correct them
going forward
he's so terrified because he'll kill him
so he's like we all make mistakes ever
we all have a guy captured and tortured
on closed circuit television while we
instruct the captors how exactly to
torture him we've all made mistakes
mulligan
and
greg norman is his job now is just to
defend the saudi human rights record
uh which by the way thank god america
set up that labyrinth of secret torture
prisons
during uh the iraq and afghanistan war
so you could he could really just kind
of point to that big hey man
there was a lot of people that we
tortured that probably had nothing to do
with anything
so thank god uh we've our moral
authority's diminished but i would this
is a big thing for you because you
really like golf they're breaking up the
pga tour uh phil might not defend his
title this year uh but all right shut up
but this is
he's really into he likes golf you know
what i mean it's like i used to be a
swimmer he used to be a golfer
how insane would it be
if i still cared
about swimming
less insane i was a really good swimmer
when i was eight
yeah but but then there's the olympics
there's there's there's some uh you know
spirit around swimming i think in this
country there's not no i mean every four
years absolutely not i mean there's a
spirit around maybe the olympics but
yeah that's what i mean it would be
insane yes if i was cared
about swimming i haven't done it
competitively in years
and but i i love ben's passion for it
but it's just a little absurd
and it gets to a point where it's it's
disgusting
i find it endearing he's yeah how much
does he owe bones in makai hundreds of
thousands who cares
dude these names he comes up with
are [ __ ] why i think he makes them up
you didn't make that up no it's adam
bones mccoy he's in a golf announcer now
he retired from caddying for phil and
people thought he wanted to be a
broadcaster turns out he just was i
guess was owed a bunch of money from
phil so what do you think mickelson does
he goes to the casino and gets really
wacky no he plays he plays golf with
like jordan and guys like that and just
does massive bets
and loses
isn't he professional isn't that the
whole point no because he runs on
adrenaline he probably goes oh for a
million bucks i'll hit it over this tree
and slice it onto the green like wait he
does dumb [ __ ] like that yeah he's like
gambling well he deserves to be in a
[ __ ] debtor's prison
if he's doing [ __ ] like that like let me
watch me bounce it off a rock a million
bucks
if he's doing stupid [ __ ]
i thought at least he was like if we if
i win i get like and he's doing crazy
like carnival acts on a golf course
for money what kind of sick [ __ ]
is this guy
he's very centric
for sure
uh well we wish the best we are big fans
of saudis here i love them i love a
culture of
rich people who smoke and a culture of
quiet women
and i've never in the world been around
saudi women and went oh my god will they
shut up
it's never happened they are a quiet
uh group of women
and i'm also everyone's like oh they're
being abused with the thing i'm like you
know what i i don't think so they seem
happy and i'm not bothered by it
if so let's stop going around the world
telling everybody how they're being
abused and because all we do in this
country is tell people how they're not
being abused
they go well they can't take off their
thing
the abaya or the burqa whatever it's
called
although women in saudi arabia can apply
for drivers driving licenses without
needing permission from a male guardian
they still need that permission to
travel abroad and that is
fine
that's absolutely fine
i mean ida what is your issue with that
you're a modern arab woman
yeah i mean i'm iranian so there's a i
think there's a little like beef with
arabs and persians um
why i don't i mean listen i don't mind
this it's all the same to me
yeah y'all eat hummus i mean listen i
live in america so it's practically all
the same to me too when's the last time
you were in iran oh god when i was six
or seven oh so you don't remember
anything no i remember it i remember i
remember as much as i need to remember
right to be an american yeah
no i'm kidding i'm very i like uh the
iranian
culture i don't mind the saudis staying
there if that's what they uh
choose to do i don't think they have any
choice but uh yeah i have no opinion one
way or the other
here's my thing
is it oppressive to the women
there's an argument to be made that
being that having to ask for permission
to travel is oppressive yeah there's
also an argument to be made that it's a
better
way to do it
you know what i mean if you're a man
saudi arabia is a wonderland
oh that sounds incredible yeah it's like
sam talent i don't want to give away his
joke but he has such a great joke where
he goes blank is for the boys he goes
you know
oh yeah muslim heavens for the boys yeah
he has such a great joke that we've now
given away but the point is
i think whatever he's done in a bunch uh
you know the reality is i don't get
involved i don't tell people what to do
in my own country and i don't tell
people what to do in saudi arabia and if
the women are not into it over there
they can you know you do it they can do
another thing
they can do another thing but yeah
you know i don't i'm not like one of
these guys who's like you gotta do it
like we do it
do it like you do it but i'm very big
fans of the saudis um and i think and
and i i really like what they've done
for beverly hills
no truly and i like just the kind of
vibe i like the vibe of beverly hills i
like the big rolls-royces and the bling
and a lot of that's very persian but i i
like that i like that and it's for me
and uh so we wish them well and i hope
this live golf thing is good and i hope
that it's [ __ ] blinged out like i
hope it's like saudi style like the
caddies you said maybe they'd be like
little pink rolls royces
and i just hope that it is [ __ ]
awesome i hope it's not like this waspy
boring sport that you know who cares i
want it to be really really cool again
yeah they're very gaudy they're daunting
very ostentatious like they're they're
very in your face but um the women enjoy
none of that i think uh
well we don't know what they're enjoying
that's the great thing about the culture
it's a mystery yeah yeah they could
really be having fun you're right the
other thing is they might be having more
fun than we know it might be fun to be
covered all the time you're in your own
little world and you're giggling yeah
and you're laughing with your friends
just ask for permission to have fun
who needs to travel abroad first of all
i mean can you imagine like
who need can you imagine american women
figuring out a good reason to travel
abroad why do you want to go abroad get
drunk in your yard you're not going to
learn anything american women aren't
going abroad to learn things they're
going to get [ __ ] up and accuse some
poor sailor a rape
[Laughter]